hi Dale and where did you go run junk
we're dunking on Candyland basketball
stuff sunk wait
Oh what do we do don't know that wasn't
us I don't know I'm not hiding in it oh
let's go get jump though holy [ __ ] oh
yes it is
is impact on or off I don't know dunk is
its own game I don't know what all Tsar
for it
oh my shot you have to make it for that
yo [ __ ] apocalypse oh boy
okay well I'm pretty well yeah you jump
high enough to do it I did it boy oh
[ __ ] this is gonna be dope didn't blast
I'm not the bailout man last that is the
optimum where am i what is life what is
that the perfect stroke bro I just had a
real primo stroke that I'm not going in
of all the roads I've seen goddamn
beautiful that [ __ ] gotta get under
testicle at the by got it double bogey I
snuck is that ice cream no no it's
clearly balls world your eyes are
testicle
my mistake that one's a testicle also
there's some cream on it oh wow
that's Harley bring it full circle there
huh Oh nailed it you gotta see some [ __ ]
[ __ ] yeah we do you wait you high
whoa oh no that's at an angle thank God
you bring this back I can broke that may
not be any dudes
oh no I learned it in the [ __ ] [ __ ] I
know now
oh oh oh no don't what I'll all are
sucking on art oh yeah this motors
[ __ ] by the way I just saying that
movie the last one what well everything
about this game is [ __ ] playing with
you guys whoa what I went up through it
and back down and it doesn't sound no
that's not how swear don't work Jack
Irish
you'll play basketball come on hey guys
how's it going
hey Rob oh I'm here now where have you
been on my own adventure but you're
going to adventures two people you're
doing great Bob
I believe in you I believe in don't feel
this way for it is coming yeah I could
bottle yeah well think you're moving
yeah you're doing it oh you were doing
it well somehow that happy I think you
went through the wrong oh come on off
the rim big joke hey I think I guess
that well I believe oh how bad wait okay
I thought I had I thought they gave me I
was so used to myself being in the last
place that I was like hey why do I have
nine strokes and I realized I don't suck
on this game oh there's a different ramp
hey don't make fun of my hey my girl
off-screen I accidentally got a far
point yeah me too I got intense Lee did
it because I'm good and not actually
just Byron oh oh we are saying it's Ava
do anything else okay do you get me Oh
Jack you're something like a taste
course Oh Frick dude go ball go god no
going oh hey you know what I just saw
the butterflies are pop-tarts that's
really cool
Oh for [ __ ] sake that's a good deal
pay up guys they're toaster pastries not
look they're toaster pastries you can
see one on bob screen and look the
broccoli has oh my god [ __ ] me I'm done
there we go this good guys great this
does wholesome trendy fun time you know
oh yeah you know it is Bubba ah cheese
[ __ ] oh she's good well I wasn't right
the thing go bald wrap it up
Oh Nelly shouldn't have followed way
that was mistake
I've already to go through those windows
oh yeah oh hey what hey what's up wait I
got a bogey
guys guys I got a bogey guys are you
happy for me I got a boat yeah the boats
are nice
well I'm just going to go down the
middle talk about a waste of time no hey
Eddie I made it in yeah you got top of
the ramp yeah you have to just play
sucker
wait you're going terribly Wade you're
just saying a whole load there come on
now what like the rubbish in anymore I
think I'm good anybody else want to pick
up your really underperforming on this
whole life ah well my life [ __ ]
but the focusing you're hitting the rim
idiotic further away my life all right
fortunately what kind of third dimension
is this way what you're winning yeah I
am winning because I'm a winner guys ah
[ __ ] yeah I nailed that I did indeed I
did
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah the jelly bounce
is just super vital baby's evil evil
baby I got a birdie
we all take it I don't care ah why are
you murdering Eagle babies marl Ammon
I'm slamming ha ha I'm not slamming
Eagle babies I want to be very clear I'm
just I'm saying I have an eagle thank
you that's the title the episode no no
no Marc tire pressure and clarity baby's
lamb and eagle babies what what of it
yeah military name I'm an eagle it's how
he survives of basketball terrific ah go
and watch actually maybe put your uh
which six lamb an eagle babies in here
coming yes my military name is fat said
yes I just made that up I have decided
you're very sad for sure you hairy me
naughty Oh
or are we trying to go right now yeah
oh yes bogey bogey bogey bogey bogey
oh he bogeyed ha ha I thought a jack ha
sorry
oh no I'm really mean this round I was
invited Odin om really mean I don't know
why what the hell you're stuck Oh what I
got kick OH no matter that I was so mean
Jack left I'm sorry
hi sorry we're waiting he can't handle a
little mark winning ok it's all a from
the abit ok
Oh got it in Oh No doughnuts are bad oh
please hey you can bypassing the Dillon
completely look at that [ __ ] parently
Nalin a mark dope Oh didn't nail it got
it no I nailed it I nailed it guys
I was lost my second oh oh yeah Jack
you're really moving up the ranks there
yeah yeah how did you get past the
doughnut like that how does that count
is it going in whatever all can you
stamp away from your microphone and
scream with your hands Cup as if you're
playing the game with us can you do that
for us I don't know what you did you got
a higher if you got a bogey I think I
think you got rocky there's two hoops
Jack what's your bring here to go
Hawking God where Sunday me Oh God holy
[ __ ] I did know thousand three
microphones O'Donnell talking about blue
yetis you talking about [ __ ] blue
yetis don't get me started
no that was the hose to the hose 11 that
wasn't that well for [ __ ] dick no bad at
getting this last shot and uh why did I
go up the ramp I didn't need to do that
no go to bang Oh No
so do you guys want to cut it cut it
early call me a winner and then just
uh get Jack back and I'll be hit yeah
mark Moses let's start over
hi boat I'd rather play with Jack Dunn
be the winner already lucky where you
voted ok nevermind then files trying to
be all like you know hey I'm making a
[ __ ] what [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] am I
the only one here still yeah keep going
Bob you can win it do we want dunk or
something else all mouth yeah we just
have goofy [ __ ] like jumps and physics
and ball shapes and bullshitter
I want that welcome Oh intro sucka Oh
fantasy sneeze OH - crashing watching
first of joint ass hairs ass chairs well
what other kind of chair would they have
face Cheers small last year's but can we
jump and [ __ ] guys the back are doing a
macron ooh that's pretty neat but the
technical term for it a smacker do ya
are we shapes
wow there's [ __ ] invincible [ __ ]
on the ground here ya know we throw deca
heat run
yeah when we really the paper machine
just perpetually are we that we always
random every it's random every hole are
we always behind wait are we bad no wait
I wanted to be that or that random
forever right now our ornament oh you
have a [ __ ] ball the hole oh [ __ ]
ornaments oh yeah ha ha ha ha
I don't I thought that was going through
Bob oh oh
I swear Bob's bongos we gonna watch that
business Bob it might get in the way
yeah I see all this lag too I think it's
because wave Genki gigabit ain't quite
the same as my los angeles gigabit yeah
30 minutes to download one gulf map go
did it till 30 minutes did it or did it
take not 30 minutes oh yeah got it or
didn't did it I don't know we got a dead
Fox pit
we don't have any but I'm Wade that's
you wait that's you that's him that's
what he sounds like that's why I say
like the most accurate impression I've
ever seen yeah better be what oh well
that's all you're supposed to do
Oh show what holy shitsnacks we're
calling you I think we need to wrap all
the way over to that [ __ ]
hey Brooke what their booty yeah hit me
you can't blame me for you hitting me
like an intensity where the hole is hey
hole I found you hey whoa hey oh hey hey
hey hold play Oh coupon my wife in the
hall already prepare to suck up ahh
I'm already in the a priori as a second
dog got a doc suck a doc follow me a
dick so good dick oh I was gonna get
close I'll mark up Oh
Thank You giggles everybody off ha ha
their cuts are really helping me man am
i encouraging you know I'm trying to be
encouraging one shot was open turf now
[ __ ]
ah [ __ ] you that's my answer
I thought you were the nice one no
that's clearly not true
I walk where are we going
cut pants Wow ok I'm backwards now I
don't understand where we're supposed to
go so we have to wrap up this wall and
go to the right I think ok you just jump
it yeah you could if you're right you're
not stupid
oh thank God thank you for rubbing it in
oh god I [ __ ] it up few way don't
worry oh [ __ ] I'm gonna run it-it's
wrong hole ok [ __ ] no no oh come on
ornament come on Luke ornament why don't
you jump when you're supposed to jump
yeah be quick draw I'm not pretty quick
guys
whoa [ __ ] I'm out of tracks hey I'm here
I may be not abstract
I may be uh [ __ ] going to things doing
whole your slave inside yeah still
ringing always going to voicemail
are you talking hi this is Amy my
boyfriend's really quick it sucks
oh my god were hockey puck oh Lisa I
fell into the universe guys okay I'm Jo
fighting
[ __ ] you guys are good go team I hope
you all go to salsa Marge what happened
to you I don't know what happened you
did like fell into the abyss a no it
happens every topic for this guy's ah
because I actually did oh what the [ __ ]
what is involved in it star oh so it's
like it's like a Fisher it's like a bang
bang oh I got a douche or a whoosh or a
minute God no no [ __ ] me god I don't do
much should I go for two I go to fancy
with my shots yeah you gotta get what I
call my girlfriend the whoosh so please
don't do isn't that her dark name Wow
you were hell on here wow this looks
like stupid oh hey all drinks oh I fell
off I don't know no way the hell this is
gonna work there's no way oh oh was it
correct I am also correct there I didn't
do it there's no way the fudge yeah what
the [ __ ] I made it
no stop it I get the [ __ ] target made
it I got it I got I got a hoppy Jaime oh
yes good luck jack oh oh oh yeah good
luck wait good luck jack oh the pain
where who's gonna shoot outside the hole
in mine but because I was in there so
soon and all not only that you guys all
stuck under Bob I did it you guys also
missed the 61 stroke I took the lead I
did it guys good job link oh Lord I
blink oh boy
oh no you know about that we want to do
P my filling up Oh
I mean a good boy hey [ __ ] me oh yeah I
made it
[ __ ] me oh God oh [ __ ] me up you're
making it hard
I'll talk me huh infinity monetize Oh
creamier why jacket but I would you
think it's the D monetize me challenge
just see see how quickly
oh oh okay watch it work [ __ ] are you
worried you can oh god oh my god you
know this is the end for me I am Sifu No
[Music]
whoa
okay if I can make it in this melon hole
nope nope no longer
[Music]
hey we all equally fine
go see oh that's good that's comforting
here I go again on all [ __ ] what is I'm
gonna get across our way up it's not
very positive no this ain't gonna happen
what that [ __ ] who I made it oh so close
I'm so close
ah just give up you guys suck
I'm amazing at this can I be the okay
lyrical backwards oh god damn it oh I
made it yeah yes ready
[ __ ] hell god damn it took me like it
was frustrated from the time I was
inches from oh [ __ ] the car oh yes yes I
character it's not even about until jazz
is a powerhouse for us bounce like you
me I'll pass
album art I'm gonna work you up yeah do
do re not only full power this is the
dissolution [ __ ] I think it's as good as
weak potato fed day does your honor but
I don't fetish you're not you're not
laughing at my express and cool joke
about as a Tony fetish I'm not sir are
you trying to roast Jack with that yeah
that was a good roast and my knife is
like I felt like really potatoes so I
kind of feel partially roasted I felt
like you know that was what it was going
for it unless you say unless he's got
like a keto diet and he can't do
starches or carbs in general that's
gonna keep doing the same thing oh oh I
can't go any uh is John strokes and you
guys I was there guy
damn it listen to him backing away from
his mic potatoes at play diet did I come
boo Jamal
[ __ ] oh I 92 the river birdie eat my
kombucha [ __ ] you like hey what's up
sexy Denis well I'm gonna suck some hair
here I'll join you guys later
I got a bogan you guys ever had
conveyance upwe guys ever heard of
flight into the red carpet it's
disgusting
look at that what would it do to have
you had I could have happened otherwise
than wash and let you have like the
super raw ultra unfiltered kombucha that
is literally awful which I wouldn't
recommend where do we go did I find it
didn't work I thought it accidentally I
didn't work at all guys I'm a genius and
you all know that doesn't seem right at
all end of end of story
oh man I got par [ __ ] I got I got our
vows no baby no they're always so hard
Wow nope why I'm very bad 5x poorly upon
you there we go
Oh mark then - look at you buddy I've
been in baby I been I was in the whole
time don't ask me if I'm in yeah what if
you're David oh okay I don't know if you
did that one to yourself give one stroke
left get it way to do it buddy
you'll even be would you make it moms
spaghetti oh oh oh oh oh oh the work of
a cheater I'm a cheater [ __ ] em I keep
touching well I don't touch you
I got more i just got par i'm not even
kidding you how you know be goin holy
funny detroit room me never heard the
tree
oh yeah oh oh
wait how did you do that I'm staying oh
let's hit him away from the mark oh man
not moving very good yeah oh no sure
Zach no Zach no Zach no
we shall love your jacket today no God
bag but we might we'll sell the job how
that's not between that's just an
obsession I can't go between Morgan I'm
literally climbing bouncer well maybe
all the SS fangirl you up yet no just
now I helped Jack you could be the best
whatever whatever
oh well Bob's having a fun time the rest
of us over you're sucking [ __ ] whoa hey
if any of us are sucking [ __ ] it's me
yeah well why did I go that way whoa God
I made it
I did pretty good actually oh that's not
what I wanted to do oh no that's not
what I wanted to do fun clothes
ah yeah well you're lucky you were
scooting on your butt over there I was
on my side I got a little clock go in
the hole hey well you guys are all into
the hundred look at you guys oh shut up
Bob shut up shut up are we we normal Oh
God oh whoa we're bouncing ball or we're
palpable oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
please why do you watch I'll get a jump
where you going I'm going back to the
library are going now I'm window where
to me going party is tomorrow
Hey Oh spaghetti and mozzarella I'm a
widow
hey go
oh you did it wait how do you think you
did something wait yeah I found last
place oh oh
on target but not enough power point got
it no I'm no lead feeling from there's a
tie between danger oh well you're making
it Adam every eyeball a septic eye you
can't just click all everyone's eyes
can't do that and will it can real dead
okay
every Audrey you know that we're getting
a good idea guy every cube is tied about
them every few every one of them don't
don't don't you cut up Neil yeah have on
the field that's ah yeah yeah is your
same logic it's the same logic loco
don't you go Joel oh yes a little
variable clue
whatever Lulu there's a baby heading
accounts we hey I got 12 at 11 Bri
already got why watch is why I Jeff Oh
dumb I didn't matter I just bounced cuz
I'm it ruin egg holy [ __ ] I'm about to
fire oh come on ah where do we go where
we're going
oh my god we're not gonna do that that's
not good oh oh oh who made it up not me
[ __ ] uh-huh that is not gonna work so
would it be a bounce me up I made it up
I made it up I made it up boys no cut to
the hole
there's a shortcut to the hole I didn't
know that oh go in the hole
laughter the whole gasm oh yeah that's
I'm just gonna take my full strokes and
go home directly into the hole I'll win
because of that oh well hey hey now hey
I have the greatest ever those toilets
why do you do this only why are you like
this
Oh what are we big ornaments I'm not a
[ __ ] shrimp
we're big ornaments [ __ ] you big [ __ ]
douchebag ornament ha ha
wait where do we go hello around visit
we're gonna go oh oh oh I am where we go
yeah jack hey oh I'm there - thank you
very much oh god damn it
big bucket - bag ornaments nah oh no no
no no no no no Ellie we're going on with
one hole after this yeah okay come down
just why all right you got it hey
there's the hole Bob that way you guys
got to it work that way okay that's
gonna close royal authentic tank yeah if
there's two of them in the brain you
can't claim it
you can't big eyes poor oh oh oh not
like what I did not what I did
oh no I'm a stupid uber that we all know
we're now it worked out
when it's okay I'll come on really
I'm going for guys Barsky scribble a new
ski Oh Oh what is this
Wow I'm a genius multi-piece I got oh
hey what's up boys party in the whole
party in the whole party I got far too
yeah because you're bad oh maybe you
shouldn't have taken your eyes out and
put them in jars then you'd be able to
see it if you wanted a full speed that
[ __ ] oh hey Jack my [ __ ] life into
the hole oh yeah - chance yeah
ah there ah I drop the board flat hey
guys I won something good job
[Music]